bonjour à tous je suis rentrée au lycée
français de barcelone en septembre 2011
et lorsque je quitterai après
l'obtention de mon bac donc dans deux
ans je n'aurais pas fait quinze ans sur
les bancs de l'école et ce sont encore
quelques années d'études qui m'attendent
bien que durant cette année de seconde
le temps passé en classe représentera
2155 heures oui c'est beaucoup mais ce
sont en fait née 155 heures
d'apprentissage de découverte des
changes et de transmission de savoirs et
de valeurs et c'est sans compter le
travail réalisé en dehors des cours
c'est le cas somme toute assez classique
de n'importe quel enfant et adolescent
me diriez vous et bien nous non ce n'est
malheureusement pas le quotidien tous
les enfants et je brille trop souvent la
chance que j'ai de pouvoir bénéficier de
cet enseignement d'une instruction de
qualité le tout dans un cadre précis et
qui suit elle respecte un programme mon
lycée lui un partenariat avec
l'organisme de formation aux
ambassadeurs cette année j'ai en plus ce
privilège de pouvoir préparer le brevet
d'initiation à l'aéronautique
il permet de valider des connaissances
de base en aéronautique notamment
l'histoire navigation connaissance des
aéronefs météorologie etc
les cours sont dispensés par les pilotes
chevronnés et la formation se solde par
un véritable vol d'initiation durant
lequel chaque diplômé pilote un avion
pendant une heure inutile de vous dire
que j'ai hâte d'être
je ne peux plus prendre l'avion sans en
faire la description technique sans
m'interroger sur les actions des pilotes
ou encore sur les conditions
météorologiques et nous allons
rencontrer ce qui n'est pas toujours de
tout repos pour ceux qui m'accompagnent
l'étude de l'histoire de l'aéronautique
et du spatial m'ont permis de découvrir
les pionnière de l'aviation
comment ne pas admirer ces femmes
j'aurais forcément une pensée pour elle
lors de mon voile d'initiation le
premier brevet de pilote obtenu par une
femme date de 1906 et ses hélices de
roche qui a ouvert la voie
parmi les grands noms féminins des
pionnières de l'aviation figure phoebe
faire gréve omri première mécanicien en
aéronautique
adrienne bolland qui a franchi la
cordillère des andes en 1921
hélène boucher quatrième femme à obtenir
son brevet de pilote professionnel
championne de voltige qui a battu de
nombreux records de vitesse
elles ont toutes mené d'autres combats
pour que les femmes joue un vrai rôle
dans notre société notamment pour
l'obtention de droits de vote
cette passion cette folie leur aura
parfois coûté la vie à meilleure offre
première femme à traverser seul
l'atlantique en avion a disparu en mer
alors qu'elle avait entrepris un tour du
monde
il n'est plus à prouver que la
stimulation intellectuelle des enfants
et adolescents conditionnent leur futur
et leur développement
elle contribuer à la reconstruction
personnelle voire professionnels elles
fassent leur identité
et leur permet de devenir des personnes
libres et responsables alors bon je ne
sais pas encore si j'exercerai un métier
lié à l'aéronautique mais cet
enseignement cette expérience des gens
rencontrés nous servira forcément dans
le futur alors oui je pense que je peux
dire que j'ai beaucoup de chance ce qui
devrait être un droit fondamental
une évidence demeure encore trop souvent
un privilège pour un interdit pour
certains enfants en france 4 juridique
est posée est claire et ne pas garantir
une éducation digne de ce nom peut être
pas assez mais d'emprisonnement et d'une
amende
donc dans notre système éducatif c'est
celui qui prive son enfant d'une
éducation de qualité qui est pointé du
doigt
mais il n'est pas le cas partout d'après
riche en 2018 à l'échelle mondiale un
jeune sur cinq enfants et adolescents
confondues ils n'étaient pas scolarisés
et ce sont les fils tu représente un
quart de la catégorie parmi des la plus
importante des exclus du système
éducatif
les filles j'ai été très touchée par
l'une des dernières campagnes de l'eau
anne le cash sans un mot tout est dit
parce que nous sommes en 2019 et dans
certains pays les filles arrêtent
l'école lorsqu'elles deviennent des
femmes
c'est à dire lorsqu'elles ont leurs
premières règles ou encore lorsqu elles
sont mariées de force à toulouse ou 14
ans donc je vais décider de vous la
raconter il s'agit d'une vidéo qui met
en scène une femme et sa fille en
afrique
la mère prépare le sac et de sa fille
elles prennent le chemin de l'école et
finissent par se séparer devant les
portes
c'est là qu'on comprend que c'est la
mère qui va à l'école ménopause et elle
est plus victime de discrimination et
peut à nouveau se rendre à l'école
tandis que sa fille et déscolarisés et
doit rester à la maison pour accomplir
des tâches ménagères caire indiquent
qu'en inde
ce sont 23 millions de filles qui
arrêtent et comme chaque année lors de
leurs règles en afrique c'est une fille
sur 10 non mais quel gâchis
d'autant que la lutte contre la pauvreté
passe par l'éducation des filles ouvrir
les portes des écolos fi permettra de
mieux maîtriser la sens
et le taux de grossesses celui des
mariages et permettrait en général
d'augmenter leurs revenus personnels de
réduire ainsi la pauvreté dans leur pays
en 2018 selon wang yu hwan 132 millions
de filles entre 6 et 17 ans n'étaient
pas scolarisés
imaginez un seul instant les progrès et
avancé que nous sommes non susceptible
d'obtenir si nous n'étions pas priver de
cette matière grise on pouvait faire
bien des choses je pense notamment à
l'un des plus grandes équipes que nous
avons avoir relevé la protection de
l'environnement puisqu'il concerne tous
les genres ne nous privons pas de la
capacité des femmes pour faire avancer
les choses
moi personnellement j'ai mon premier
petit potager alors c'était tomates
cerises herbes aromatiques salade
rien d'extravagant à l'âge de 16 ans et
ça m'a permis de découvrir le soin qu'il
fallait apporter à mes deux cultures
la patiente il fallait faire preuve et
enfin le prix plaisir que procure et la
récolte de ses propres productions
mais c'est parce que j'ai été
sensibilisée et c'est notamment à
l'école que je suis plus vigilante de
temps que j'ai vécu en allemagne et j'ai
découvert très tôt le système de
consigne
les panneaux solaires et les sacs
réutilisables l'absence d'emballage sur
certains produits et c'est encore une
preuve de l'importance de l'émancipation
des femmes et de leur accès à
l'éducation puisque les fillettes et
adolescentes d'aujourd'hui sont aussi
les consommatrices les industriels et
les productrices de demain autant que
les hommes mais l'environnement scolaire
n'est pas qu'un lieu d'échangés
d'apprentissage scolarisés les fils et
leur donne accès à cette mini société
ce lieu de rencontre de création
d'imagination deux des filles de joie et
même parfois de déception si leur
permettre de se confronter aux autres
la socialisation le respect des
différences
c'est développer de nouvelles
compétences c'est aussi les
responsabiliser pour qu'elles soient
plus tard maîtresses de leur choix
certains stéréotypes tels que celui de
la femme cantonné aux tâches ménagères
ont la peau dure et conduisent encore
aujourd'hui à des situations aberrantes
une jeune femme instruite se construit
en prenant conscience du monde qui
l'entourent en trouvant des modèles en
dehors de ça c'est les familiales en
sortant de sa zone de confort en
envisageant ce qu'elle souhaite
améliorer et les moyens qu'elle va se
donner pour y arriver mais l'instruction
appel l'instruction et éveille la
curiosité témoin de mes nombreuses
transformations des changements
physiologiques et psychologiques
l'école n'est que le début d'un long
joliment les changements qui m'attendent
se feront dans la continuité mais elle
est un passage clé dans la constitution
de mon identité qui n'a pas fini
d'évoluer
plus j'avance dans ma scolarité et plus
la relation qui s'instaure avec mes
professeurs évoluent ils deviennent de
véritables conseillers dans les choix
que je vais être amené à faire pour mon
avenir
l'école nous permet de vous impliquer
très tôt dans différents projets qu'il
soit collectif ou individuel
à titre d'exemple je me souviens que en
cm2 j'ai pu participer à la création
d'un mur végétal et en scène et dans par
l'instinct primaire est en cm2 justement
avec deux classes de troisième
j'ai pu participer au projet de
l'artiste jr qui s'est nommé inside out
et qui avait en fait comme message à
prendre ensemble c'est vivre ensemble
donc bon à cette occasion que j'ai pu
que l'amour et avec d'autres enfants
j'ai pu découvrir le travail de cet
artiste j'ai fait chira la thématique
vivre ensemble et m'expliquer devant des
caméras alors c'est aussi ce type
d'expérience qui me fait grandir cette
heure est d'ailleurs toujours exposés
sur les murs du lycée français de
barcelone et vous l'aurez peut-être
constaté en arrivant j'ai
personnellement toujours voulu être
impliqué dans la vie de ma classe et de
mon école et depuis la 6e j'ai quasiment
toujours été déléguée de classe
suppléante
grâce à cela j'ai pu découvrir plus en
détail le fonctionnement de mon
établissement l'école me donne tous les
moyens de démarrer ma vie avec les mêmes
naquit que l'ensemble de mes camarades
elle m'a permis de me construire dans le
respect de mes différences et de ma
liberté de pensée et d'expression et
durant toute ma scolarité
je ne crois pas m'être posé une seule
fois la question
demont égalité vis-à-vis de mes
camarades masculins parce que j'ai ma
place ici autant que n'importe qui
tandis que je commencerai par effectué
mon premier vol d'ici quelques mois
s'est dotée de la plus pacifique des
arbres l'instruction que je prendrai mon
envol dans quelques années
plus elles apprendront de nouvelles
choses via l'accès à une instruction de
qualité plus les femmes auront envie
d'en découvrir d'autres et par la suite
de scolariser leurs propres enfants
la question de la sco à l'aise de la
scolarisation des filles ne se posera
plus est sa légitimité s'imposera alors
à toutes les filles les adolescentes et
les jeunes femmes aujourd'hui étudiant
collégiennes et lycéennes
je voudrais te dire profite fons enrichi
toit de toutes les qualités de toutes
les connaissances qui te sont enseignées
parce que c'est maintenant que tu
prépares tu ton avenir j'ai alors vu
juste en dessous de tout ce qui a déjà
été accompli en matière d'éducation des
femmes mais inquiétant nous de tout ce
qu'il reste à faire
et faisons tomber des dernières
barrières financières économiques et
culturelles qui nous prive encore de
tous ses potentiels
le fameux l'avenir de l'homme et la
femme prend ici un tout autre sens et va
bien au delà du poème de louis aragon
elle est l'avenir de l'homme avec un
grand h
son avenir sociétales culturelles et
environnementales alors privilégiant son
éducation
[Applaudissements]